and as some schools open their doors cbs
news senior medical correspondent dr
tara narula
spoke to the health experts they say
they are even still doing their homework
on this to see if current safety
measures
will stop the coronavirus from spreading
among the kids he's going side to side
right buddy
school's in session at idea travis
academy elementary in midland texas
despite the state being one of the most
infected in the nation
but local transmission of the virus is
much lower
new coveted procedures here include
temperature checks
mandatory masks limited class sizes and
plexiglas
partitions we have lessons on
maintaining six feet
how to properly wash your hands how to
sanitize our table
but the public health experts we spoke
with say only some of the science behind
covid prevention is clear
dr dimitri christakis is a pediatrician
and epidemiologist
at seattle children's hospital i was on
a national academy of science um
task force about school reopening and we
looked at the science
behind a lot of the mitigation
strategies being proposed
some of them have very strong evidence
social distancing works
masks work we don't know how important
ventilation is
does it have to be six feet can it be
less than that
we don't know the answers to a lot of
those questions first and foremost kids
have to be wearing masks and adults have
to be wearing masks experts like dr
ashish jaw of harvard's global health
institute
believe the virus can spread through
respiratory droplets from coughing
sneezing or even talking this video
captured by slow motion cameras
show how particles can travel when
someone sneezes
both with a mask and without for a place
like miami-dade county it's going to be
a lot of work because they have so much
virus in their community
but for a place like new york city it'll
still be some work but not as much
because they've got the virus largely
under control
what is your advice to parents about how
to make that decision about whether to
send their child back to school
in the area where they live they should
rely on the public health
recommendations for their local area
they should look to see what mitigation
strategies their school is taking
they should take stock of their own
personal situation the decision to send
your child back to school or not
is a luxury that not every parent has
yeah and good luck trying to get kids to
socially distance tara when they
when they haven't seen their friends in
a very long time so
parents are very nervous rightfully so
what's your advice for their parents
every single parent i know gail is
asking me the same question and really
it boils down to those things that you
heard in the piece
what is the community transmission in
your area you should be aware of it are
you in a zone where
it's safe to reopen the schools also you
want to know what is your school doing
so parents should feel empowered to talk
to their school and find out what kinds
of mitigation strategies they're putting
in place
is your child a vulnerable child talk to
your pediatrician and see if they have
any concerns about your child going back
to school
and then as a parent obviously you can
do things like packing extra masks hand
sanitizer but i think one of the
important things we don't often talk
about
is just talking to our kids they're
going to be going back to something that
isn't what they're used to
they may have their own anxieties and
fears and you really want to sit down
with them and have an
honest conversation in a calm reassuring
way
where you listen to them and their
concerns and you walk them through what
to expect
yeah they take their cues from you you
got to be reassuring during these times
thank you very much tara